[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue pour cette édition
du 7 8 politiques spéciales municipal
sur tv et 78 nous sommes aujourd'hui le
21 janvier puis dans deux mois nous
serons à la veille du second tour de
l'élection municipale aujourd'hui nous
nous intéressons à cette commune de
trappes
bonsoir à lire ah ben non soir vous êtes
à la tête de liste pour que tu rappes
respire c'est une liste de gauche
d'union de la gauche a notamment soutenu
par génération dont vous êtes adhérent
je leur précise les habitants vous
connaissent déjà bien puisque vous êtes
actuellement adjoint au maire mais
aujourd'hui pour que ce soit clair aussi
pour les habitants est ce que vous
assumez le bilan de la majorité sortante
même si vous êtes tête de liste face au
maire sortant guy malandain
est-ce que vous revendiquez une partie
du bilan évidemment trappe c'est une vie
qui a considérablement changé depuis
plus de 20 ans guy malandain a su parmi
ses qualités
profitez des 350 millions d'euros de la
rénovation urbaine pour faire en sorte
que cette ville se transforme donc on a
moins de tours - d'immeubles anciens
davantage de constructions plus modernes
ultra pas changé ces changements je les
revendique j'ai participé évidemment
j'en suis fier j'ai travaillé pour ce
qui me concerne a développé notamment
les politiques de jeunesse et les
politiques sportives aux côtés de la
quarantaine de clubs sportifs de la
commune de trappes mais j'ai également
des désaccords avec le maire sortant
le premier d'entre eux tient au fait que
à mes yeux en politique il faut
respecter la parole que l'on donne en
lorsqu'il s'est présenté aux élections
municipales et moi avec dans son équipe
il s'était engagé auprès des trappistes
a effectué son dernier mandat
son quatrième et dernier mandat et il
avait indiqué qu' après 80 ans il ne se
voyait plus maire de trappes
je constate qu'aujourd'hui à 83 ans à
près de 83 ans et au terme de vingt-cinq
années à la tête de la commune il a
décidé de se représenter je considère
qu'il n'a plus ni l'énergie ni
l'imagination pour préparer l'avenir de
trappes et des trappistes trap est une
ville jeune 50 % de la population a
moins de 29 ans et je pense qu'il faut
une énergie nouvelle un souffle nouveau
il faut que tu rappes respire c'est le
nom de ma liste qu'elle respire
démocratiquement qu'elle soit capable de
porter un projet écologiste et pour cela
j'ai décidé de présenter ma candidature
accompagnés par des forces de gauche et
des citoyens et des citoyennes de la
ville de trappes
aujourd'hui ce qui vous différencie
principalement de guy malandain c'est là
je
c'est la question de l'âge la différence
c'est l'âge pas uniquement guillemin
aujourd'hui j'ai un candidat plus jeune
donc je suis plus légitimement bien sûr
que l'ombre puisqu'il devra plusieurs
candidats jeunes moi je suis un candidat
de gauche on découvre aux élections
municipales que des hommes et des femmes
essaient d'effacer leur étiquette
politique et se présente face aux
électeurs en ayant ce qu'ils sont moi je
ne ferais jamais cela je me présente
devant les trappistes en leur disant qui
je suis d'où je parle
quel projet politique je porte et je
présente un projet politique que je
revendique être de gauche
ça ne veut pas dire un projet sectaire
ou fermée j'y travaille avec des
trappistes issus d'horizons très divers
avec des militants associatifs des gens
issus des comités de quartier et des
associations de la ville
mais je construis un projet qui
revendique d'être un projet progressiste
de gauche
je suis fier de mon identité politique
et je ne souhaite pas mentir aux
électeurs pour ce qui concerne guy
malandain vous parliez des accords j'en
ai un majeur
le respect de la parole donnée je vous
disais mais un autre élément qui a créé
une rupture entre nous c'est que guy
malandain petit à petit au fur et à
mesure du mandat a décidé de se
rapprocher du parti la république en
marche des manuels macron du président
de la république
moi je suis en désaccord avec ses
orientations politiques je combats par
exemple en ce moment la réforme des
retraites qui est porté par l'exécutif
et le fait que guy malandain et jeanine
marie la première adjointe et choisi
pour la seconde de rejoindre le parti la
république en marche pour le premier
d'accepter l'investiture le soutien du
parti de la république en marche
constitue un désaccord majeur entre nous
les trappistes doivent savoir pourquoi
ils voteront au mois de mars
s'il souhaite que la ville comme depuis
presque un siècle reste à gauche avec
des politiques de solidarité
ils voteront pour la liste d'union de la
gauche que je porterai si les trappistes
au contraire souhaite que cette ville
change d'orientation mais ils auront un
candidat ait l'air même s'il se fait
passer pour un candidat sans étiquette
monsieur n'à through qui est président
du groupe
lr les républicains la droite
régionaliste est ouverte c'est parce
qu'il ya un tête de liste qui est
président du groupe plr à la région ile
de france donc il a une identité
politique qu'il doit assumer et n'ont
pas masqué et pour ce qui concerne guy
malandain
il a reçu le soutien d'un seul parti le
parti la république en marche pour ma
part je rassemble déjà effectivement le
parti de benoît hamon qui ont une
personnalité qui compte et qui a compté
pour trappe
je rassemble également j'ai eu
l'investiture d'être par le parti pardon
europe ecologie les verts ce qui compte
pour moi parce que je suis
fondamentalement écologistes et que
j'estime que tu n'as pas besoin d'un
projet écologiste et je continue à
rassembler et dans les prochains jours
et les prochaines semaines le
rassemblement autour de ma candidature
sera de plus en plus large aujourd'hui
parti communiste et rallier
officiellement à vous nous sommes en
pleine discussion vers le parti
communiste nous sommes en accord sur
presque tout il s'agira maintenant de
nous rassembler concrètement pour être
en ordre de marche dans les prochains
jours vous avez évoqué benoît hamon
ancien ministre ancien député de cette
circonscription qui compte la ville de
trappes il était présent à votre
dernière réunion et notamment aussi au
lancement de campagne il vous accompagne
pendant cette campagne il ne sera pas
sur la liste il là il annoncé sauf
changement il ya quelques jours lors de
la dernière réunion il a adressé aussi
une petite pique à votre adversaire
ottomane masrouki le qualifie
d'assistants personnels de valérie
pécresse qui aura cherché ces directives
ailleurs antoine lascault qui lui a
répondu sur les réseaux sur les réseaux
sociaux la campagne se fait aussi comme
ça aujourd'hui il fait remarquer qu'il a
été élu à trappes et qu'il a voté pour
les décisions proposées par guy
malandain tout comme vous donc vous
reprocher quoi et vous répondez quoi
aujourd'hui en tout cas à ottomane nasri
qui vous fait remarquer qu'il faut
assumer ce bilan et les choix qui ont
été faits déjà je vous dirais que
effectivement benoît hamon a apostrophé
menace trou parce qu'il le côtoie au
conseil régional et qu'ils voient
comment othman nasro fidèlement mais
prend ses consignes chez valérie
pécresse mais je rajouterai qu il les
prend également chez jean michel
fourgous qui est le maire d'elancourt et
qui avec valérie pécresse constitue un
peu le duo de parent quand vous parlez
de j'en ai chialé vous parlez de quoi
concrètement pardon quand vous parlez de
directives vous parlez de quoi contrer
veut dire concrètement que et d'ailleurs
il le revendique
ce candidat est le candidat de la droite
régionale
il a été envoyé à trappes dans laquelle
ils ne résident pas avec laquelle il n'a
aucune attache
on ne le voit pas entre deux élections
mais il vient quand il est venu en 2014
il s'est implanté politiquement à la
demande de ces deux personnalités
et ce sont eux qu'il lui dise ce qu'il
faut ou pas faire attraper ce sont des
enjeux pour eux qui dépasse très
largement la vie quotidienne et rappeler
si besoin est souvent siéger au conseil
municipal où il était et vous êtes le
porte parole de non mais
en tout cas pour ce qui concerne tant
les personnes mais aussi il a quitté le
conseil municipal en 2015 parce qu'il a
intégré la région et vous savez qu'on ne
peut pas cumuler plusieurs mandats et
donc il a défendu à la région les
dossiers qui concernent la ville de
trappes notamment
mais benoît hamon a été infiniment plus
actif à trappes que aux menaces roux ne
l'a jamais été
c'est une évidence et tous les
trappistes le reconnaissent benoît hamon
c'est quand même quelqu'un qui fait un
électeur sur deux au premier tour des
élections quand il se présentera trappe
c'est relativement massif pour revenir
aux questions de fond haute menaceront
ne vit pas à trappes l'autre menace roux
n'est pas intéressé impliqué par ce qui
se passe au quotidien attrape moi j'y
vis tous les jours j suis propriétaire
dans la ville de trappes j'y fais mes
courses et je côtoie les trappistes je
tutoie les présidents d'associations les
les membres actifs des comités de
quartier les trappistes de tous les
jours qui me tutoie également qui me
connaissent et me cauet me croise dans
la rue c'est ce qui fait que je sais ce
qu'il faut pour cette ville de trappes
je sais quel projet à la temps je sais
quelle énergie de l comporte et mon
objectif est de pouvoir porter ces
énergies de mettre en oeuvre un projet
ambitieux nous reste quelques minutes
voudrais qu'on parle du programme
maintenant et vous aurez l'occasion
d'échanger lors des débats que nous
organisons et chacun pourra échanger et
sur le fond et sur la forme sur le
programme les rythmes scolaires vous
êtes en pleine consultation les rythmes
scolaires sur la commune de trappes ont
été modifiés aujourd'hui il serait
question de l'échangé
déjà il serait question surtout de
demander leur avis aux trappistes on a
produit n'a pas été créé pendant le
mandat précédent ça a été un de mes
points des deux records avec l'équipe en
place avec guy malandain et jeanine mari
en particulier qui s'occupe du scolaire
on découvre un certain nombre de
décisions vous le savez est compris
quand on est élu de la majorité
et ça ce sont des pratiques qui sont
pour le coup celle du 20è siècle
on est aujourd'hui en 2020 on ne peut
plus mettre en oeuvre des politiques
notamment qui concerne directement la
quasi-totalité des trappistes sans leur
demander leur avis donc le b à ba c'est
de consulter de prendre les avis et
ensuite le politique peut décider il
peut se soumettre au vote de la majorité
il peut au contraire décidé de maintenir
le cap des villes comme guyancourt et
d'autres dans l'agglomération ont
organisé un référendum
les élus pouvaient défendre un point de
vue moi je défends un point de vue mais
les habitants ont le droit de débattre
les enseignants ont le droit d'exprimer
leurs avis attrape les habitants en ont
été privés et je l' ai regretté
donc je vais proposer dans les jours qui
viennent nous sommes en train de mettre
en oeuvre ce référendum
nous avons déjà en trois jours plus de
300 votants nous une dynamique très
forte à trappes pour de la part des
trappistes avec une vraie volonté de
s'exprimer sur les décisions qui les
concernent et au terme de ce référendum
je m'engage comme candidat demain comme
maire à mettre en oeuvre la décision qui
sera majoritaire
si je suis suivie dans la vie qui est le
mien est à la limite
mon avis compte est celui des milliers
de trappes y seront encore plus ce sera
formidable
si au contraire et ce sera pareil demain
quand je serai élu maire si les
habitants décident de choisir un cap
différents alors il faut accepter quand
on est élu c'est ça la modernité de se
soumettre à la majorité on va pas faire
des référendums sur toutes les questions
oui ça va faire des référendums toutes
les semaines mais sur les sujets majeurs
et celui là en fait partie
l'exécutif la mairie le maire d'une
ville doit être capable de faire un
référendum et d'écouter ce qu'ils
expriment majoritairement les trappistes
sur les autres points de programme quels
sont les axes majeurs que vous allez
développer et là aussi on aura
l'occasion d'y revenir pendant la
campagne il est encore assez tôt mais
quels sont les points majeurs pour vous
il y en a énormément il nous faudrait
pour ça au moins une heure on a pris une
heure et demie vendredi dernier devant
200 trappistes pour détailler les
mesures du programme mais je voudrais
insister sur quelques éléments qui me
semble essentiel où il faudra justement
de l'imagination et de la modernité sur
l'éducation par exemple nous sommes en
retard
pourtant du point de vue des moyens nous
mettons le paquet mais nous sommes en
retard sur des choses relativement
simple qui pourrissent la vie
quotidienne des trappistes je vous donne
un exemple si vous voulez inscrire vos
enfants à la cantine ou aux activités
périscolaires à montigny-le-bretonneux
par exemple ce n'est pas une ville de
mon band de mon bord politique
il suffit de s'inscrire deux jours avant
la date à laquelle vous voulez inscrire
votre enfant à la cantine
je vous faire sourire à auffargis petit
village des yvelines avec peu de moyens
où habite guy malandain d'ailleurs si
vous voulez inscrire vos enfants à la
cantine caj - cet attrape ville de 32
mille habitants qui a des moyens quand
même conséquent pour inscrire vos
enfants il faut le faire avant le 25 du
mois précédent parfois près d'un mois
avant la date
vous et moi nous avons dévié chargé et
parfois nous ne savons pas exactement ce
que nous ferons dans un mois et si nous
pourrons pas garder nos enfants à la
maison aussi nous devrons l'inscrire au
périscolaire ou pas puis c'est une
trentaine de secondes on va devoir
couper cet entretien on vous laisse
conclure
donc nous allons moderniser pour le coup
le fonctionnement des services
municipaux faciliter la vie des
trappistes au quotidien puis mettre le
paquet sur l'emploi sur l'insertion sur
les formations des jeunes mobilisés les
trappistes qui ont réussi les réseaux
d'entreprise pour faciliter l'insertion
professionnelle des trappistes le taux
de chômage est trop élevée chez nous il
faudra prendre ce problème à bras le
corps et je terminerai par les seniors
qui mérite toute l'attention de la
municipalité une politique en termes de
santé qui soit offensive
il faudra créer une maison
pluridisciplinaire de santé au centre
ville une mutuelle communal pour couvrir
toutes les personnes y compris âgées
nous travaillerons tous ces projets avec
les trappistes merci à l'érable et je
rappelle que vous êtes tête de liste
pour que tu rappes respire scrutin
municipal ce sera le 15 mars pour le
premier tour merci à vous merci
le maire sortant de maurepas sera
également candidat dans ce scrutin et
grégory gary astier vient de tenir une
réunion publique pour présenter ses
premiers axes de campagne les projets
qu'il souhaite mener lors d'un second
mandat
reconstruire le centre aqualudique et la
halle du marché rénové l'école de la
malle me donne ou encore la protection
de l'environnement
pour sa nouvelle candidature grégory
garer ce type aux une feuille de route
nos repas 2030 faire davantage d'actions
en faveur de la transition écologique
notamment avec le renouvellement de
paris ouest qui va être un des grands
enjeux d'avenir du territoire avec la
ville de coignières décaissement
souterrain et nationaliste avec le
carrefour dame elle me donne la volonté
de transformer paris ouest vers des
aménagements beaucoup plus durable
grégory gars restiez repart avec les
mêmes ou presque sa liste sera
renouvelée de moitié
un moyen pour le maire sortant de
continuer ses projets initiés en 2014
un mandat c'est court et je le vois tout
ce que j'ai mis en place et que mon
équipe commence à peine à sortir de
terre
donc voilà il faut de nouveaux impulser
une nouvelle dynamique avec une équipe
renouvelée cette valeur de travail pour
la ville avant de la travaille pour soi
qui me moi qui me qui me plaisent
beaucoup
et après on a des valeurs pour les
générations il en a beaucoup parlé ce
soir également vraiment de d'avoir une
ville pour toutes les générations que du
tout petits jusqu'aux seniors je suis
maman de deux enfants qui sont
maintenant scolarisés en primaire mais
qu'ils ont été
en crèche par la municipalité et tout ce
qui a été mis en oeuvre au niveau de la
petite enfance m'a beaucoup touché et je
trouve que c'est vrai qu'on a beaucoup
de chance en tant que maman d'avoir
toutes ces structures de crèches dans
ses autres projets grégory gars restiez
souhaite notamment lancé une mutuelle
communal le conseil des aînés sera en
charge du projet à maurepas le scrutin
municipal devrait voir s'affronter le
maire sortant à ismail havane et michel
chat pas tous deux élus aujourd'hui de
l'opposition fin du set 8 politique les
agendas de campagne sont à retrouver sur
notre site internet et puis prochain
rendez vous mardi prochain à 18h45
invités sonia broc maire de saint cyr
l'école est tête de liste pour la
première fois
[Musique]